[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
protester parce qu'il viole la loi
nationale et les droits de l'homme en ce
moment il met en place le passeport vert
ici dans notre pays il discrimine
beaucoup de gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
il a raison il est de nombreux droits
fondamentaux il y a un an et il ya
quelques jours encore plus nous sommes
ici sur coup que dans les personnes de
plus de 50 ans qui seront bientôt rennes
avant obligé de se faire vacciner non
marchand ces gens là ne peuvent pas
travailler lorsqu'ils sont suspendus de
leur travail sans aucune aide du
gouvernement de la famille 0 suspendu et
c'était basse
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
g
m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]